وقالت شرطه نيويورك انها لن تتسامح مع اي
عنف وذلك بتزامني مع اصدار لائحه اتهام
للرئيس السابق دون ترامب وظيفه انها
ستراجع خطط انتشار عناصرها من اجل مواكبه
التطورات الامنيه وقالت الشرطه في مذاكره
لها ان جميع الضباط يجب ان يكونوا مستعدين
للتعبئه خلال عملهم ولسيناريو والفوضى غير
العاديه حسب المذكره
معنى من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره محمد
العلمي محمد اذا هي خطوه قضائيه غير
مسبوقه في التاريخ الامريكي حيال رئيس
امريكي ماذا عن هذه الخطوه
وتشابكاتها في الداخل الامريكي
تشبكات عميقه ومرشحه لكي تزداد عمقا عبد
القادر لان البلد بالفعل يدخل في متاهه لا
يملك اي مرجعيه سابقه
يهتدي بها فيما سياتي سواء على المدى
القريب او على المدى البعيد ايضا يعني
اخطر تحدي تواجه الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
ربما منذ الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه بسبب
اختلاف معسكرين اختلافا عميقا حتى ازاء
المؤسسات التي تقليديا كانت تحظى بمصداقيه
او على الاقل معظم افراد الشعب الامريكي
حسب تسريبات في معظم الاعلام الامريكيه
الرئيس السابق
سيمثل امام المحكمه يوم الثلاثاء القادم
حسب مصادر اخرى سيكون
تسليم على الساعه الثانيه
وربع بعد ظهر نيويورك يوم الثلاثاء
ان التاسعه وربع بتوقيت مكه المكرمه في
مشهد سيكون غير مسبوق تماما في العداله
الامريكيه رئيس سابق يمد يديه لشرطي او
للشرطيه لكي تاخذ بصماته ثم لتؤخذ صورته
وثلث عليه حقوقه الدستوريه
في الجمله المتكرره في مثل هذه المناسبات
نصيحه المتهم بان اي كلام ينطق به يمكن ان
يستخدم وسيستخدم ضده في المحكمه وهذا ربما
سيكون بدايه المشاهد ربما المثيره فيما
سياتي لان الرئيس ترامب لاول مره في حياته
ربما سيفقد السيطره سواء على المستوى
المادي انه لن يستطيع التحرك الا
رجال الامن وثانيا
سيفقد السيطرته على الخطاب وحينما يمثل
امام القاضي الذي سيكشف النقاب عن صكي
الاتهام الذي تقول ايضا بعض المصادر ان
الادعاء سيوجه له اكثر من ضزينتين وتهمه
اي اكثر من 24 تهمه مصادر اخرى تتحدث عن
30 تهمه كلها منبثقه عن 130 الف دولار
التي
يشتبه او يدعي الادعاء العام ان الرئيس
السابق دفعها للممثله الاباحيه
ولكن هذه التهمه في حد ذاتها هي جنحه لكن
يبدو من هذه الثلاثين تهمه المنتظره يحاول
ادعاء العام ان يرفعها الى الى جنايه
ولكنه يحتاج في ذلك الى
اقناع المحلفين ان
السجلات التجاريه وهي تهمه في ولايه
نيويورك او جريمه جنحه لكنها تصبح جنايه
اذا اريد بها التستر على جريمه اخرى وفي
هذه الحاله هي
الانفاق الانتخابي اي انه سجل 130 الف
دولار على انها نفقات قانونيه واخذ
الاموال من التبرعات الانتخابيه وبالتالي
تصبح الجنحه جنايه لكن هناك الخشيه من ان
لا يستطيع الادعاء تاكيد هذه التهمه
وهذا سيفتح ابواب جهنم على
المؤسسه مؤسسه العداله في الولايات
المتحده وعلى النظام السياسي ككل لانه
سيعزز الانطباع وتصريحات الرئيس ترامب
ومؤيديه على ان التهم الكيديه والهدف منها
سياسي عرقله طموح الرئيس ترامب العوده الى
البيت الابيض ايضا من المحتمل ان يترك
القاضي من
المتهم ساعه ايدين
[موسيقى]
ان يصمت وان يدلي باي تصريحات وان فعل
بامكان القاضي ان يامر بسجن الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحده محمد العالمي من واشنطن
شكرا جزيلا لك